so you asked a simple question
invisibility just decades away we will
have something resembling Harry Potter's
invisibility cloak something equally
astonishing is shape-shifting when you
see science fiction movies like
Terminator 2 and you see the evil robot
turn into jelly and then mousse this way
through obstacles you say to yourself no
way no way could that happen believe it
or not we scientists are making huge
inroads into that area
it's called programmable matter matter
itself that can rearrange itself change
color change shape change conductivity
by pushing a button and here's how it
works
why is it the certain substance because
can turn liquid and ooze its way across
the room like in the movie Terminator 2
is because of atoms atoms can slide over
atoms rearrange themselves but what
happens if atoms are replaced by chips
chips that are so small they're smaller
than the head of a pin
and you can change their electric charge
by changing the electric charge they
bind and reform in different ways and
they're intelligent because each dot is
a computer chip
perhaps as powerful as a PC these are
called Katims and who's pushing this
technology the Intel Corporation the
makers of the famous Pentium chip that
drives your laptop the same company is
now investigating the next several steps
in the future the ability to have
programmable matter now think about it
it means that if I have a clump of clay
made out of thousands of millions of
little dots I push a button then the
charges rearrange themselves to form a
statue a car whatever you want this
means that I can push another button and
this clay turns into a house or I push
another button and a whole city a whole
city Rises out of the desert sounds like
science fiction but the basic steps are
being done today in fact with the
television crew I went to Carnegie
Mellon University in Pittsburgh and
photographed it of course these Katims
are quite large they're about the size
of a head of a
but it's only a matter of time before
these Katims become so microscopic and
so powerful that they'll be able to
rearrange just like what you see in
Terminator 2 just I could see what you
see in the Transformers just like what
you see in x-men comics
there was a conference at a silla mar
that made headlines around the world the
brightest minds of artificial
intelligence converged on the silla mar
and a reporter asked them a question
when will this fable singularity take
place when will the machines take over
when will machines become smarter than
us well the answer was quite interesting
among the top people assembled in one
place the answers were anything from 20
years in the future to a thousand years
in the future with some AI experts
saying never some people put it at 2029
they even give you an exact date 2029
that's going to be the moment of truth
that one day a robot will wake up wake
up in the laboratory look around and say
I am aware I'm just as smart as you in
fact I could be even smarter if I put a
few my chips in my brain other people
say not so fast not so fast because
Moore's law is going to break down the
reason why many people are so confident
about this prediction of the so-called
singularity is because of Moore's law
that computer power doubles every 18
months and it's C it's a curve that is
held sway for 50 years if you go back a
hundred years back to the time of
mechanical hand crank Computers put that
into Moore's Law and you still get a
nice fit so believe it or not Moore's
law has been in operation for about a
hundred years going back to hand crank
calculators with computer power doubling
every 18 months well can this go on
forever
and the answer is no because eventually
physics takes over and that is physics
says that silicon is unstable at the
molecular level transistors get so small
so powerful and they generate so much
heat that the silicon chip melts and
electrons leak out because of the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle you
don't know where the electron is anymore
therefore we physicists are looking for
replacements
silicon the post silicon era will be
about 10 to 15 years in the future
Silicon Valley could become a Rust Belt
think about it every Christmas your PC's
your computers your gadgets will be just
as powerful as they were the previous
year and then the question is are you
gonna buy are you going to buy any more
computer products for Christmas time
knowing that they're just as powerful as
they were the previous year
probably not which means that the
computer industry could begin to begin
to shake as a consequence so we
physicists are looking at optical
computers quantum computers DNA
computers protein computers all sorts of
different kinds of architecture down to
the molecular down to the atomic down to
the microscopic realm but none of them
are ready for primetime yet so my answer
is I don't know all I'm saying is
there's vast uncertainties in projecting
Moore's law into the future however I
would say by end of the century I would
say by end of the century it is
definitely conceivable that if we work
out the technical problems we might be
able to create machines that are smart
as us right now our machines are as
smart as insects eventually they'll be
smart as mice after that they'll be
smart as dogs and cats probably by the
end of the century who knows they'll be
as smart as monkeys at that point they
could become potentially dangerous
because monkeys can formulate their own
plans they don't have to listen to you
they can formulate their own strategies
their own goals and I would say
therefore at that point let's put a chip
in their brain to shut them off if they
get murderous thoughts Isaac Asimov
advocated something like that with his
three laws I say hey put a chip in their
brain to shut them off if they start to
get murderous
I say looking at the next 100 years that
there are two trends in the world today
the first trend is toward what we call a
type one civilization a planetary
civilization a civilization that
resembles something out of Buck Rogers
or Flash Gordon a type two civilization
is stellar they consume so much energy
they can play with stars that's for
example the Federation of Planets is
Star Trek Star Trek would represent the
typical type to civilization then we
have type 3 which is galactic like the
Borg or Independence Day or the Empire
of the Empire Strikes Back
that is a type 3 civilization which is
truly galactic now by the time you reach
type 2 you are immortal nothing known to
science can destroy a type two
civilization comets meteors earthquakes
even a supernova a type two civilization
would be able to survive even a
supernova the danger is the transition
between type zero and type one and
that's where we are today we are a type
0 civilization we get our energy from
dead plants oil and coal but if you get
a calculator you can calculate when we
will attain type 1 status the answer is
in about a hundred years we will become
planetary we'll be able to harness all
the energy output of the planet earth
will play with the weather earthquakes
volcanoes anything planetary we will
play with the danger period is now
because we still have the savagery we
still have all the passions we have all
the sectarian fundamentalist ideas
circulating around but we also have
nuclear weapons we have chemical
biological weapons capable of wiping out
life on Earth so I see two trends in the
world today the first trend is toward a
multicultural scientific tolerant
society and everywhere I go I see
aspects of that birth for example what
is the internet many people have written
about the Internet
billions and billions of words written
about the internet but to me as a
physicist the Internet is the beginning
of a type one telephone system a
planetary telephone system so we're
privileged to be alive to witness the
birth of type 1 technology a planetary
telephone system what is English English
is the beginning of a type 1 language
everywhere I go around the earth people
speak English because that's the lingua
franca of science technology business
they all speak English it is the number
one second language on the planet Earth
and what is the European Union the
European Union is the beginning of a
type-1 economy and how come these
European countries which have
slaughtered each other ever since the
ice melted 10,000 years ago how come
they have banded together put aside
their differences to create the European
Union well to compete with us and who
are we we are NAFTA so we're beginning
to see the beginning of a type-1 economy
as well then we're beginning to see the
beginning of a type-1 culture everywhere
I go you turn on the radio what do you
hear rock and roll you hear rap music
you hear youth music Youth music is now
planetary knows no boundaries around the
planet Earth everywhere I go I see
high-fashion Chanel Gucci Bags they were
producing the birth of a planetary
fashion also sports take a look at the
Olympics take a look at soccer we're
seeing the beginning of a tribal
initiation rite called sports being
turned into a planetary initiation rite
that unifies the entire planet so
whenever I open the newspaper every
headline I see in the newspaper points
to the birth pangs of a type one
civilization information however every
time I open the newspaper I also see the
opposite trend as well what is terrorism
terrorism in some sense is a reaction
against the creation of a type one
civilization
now most terrorists cannot articulate
this they don't even know what the hell
I'm talking about
but what they're reacting to is not
modernism with the reacting to is the
fact that we're headed toward a
multicultural tolerant scientific
society and that's what they don't want
they don't want science they want a
theocracy
they don't want multiculturalism they
want mono culturalism so instinctively
they don't like the the march toward a
type one civilization
now which tendency will win I don't know
but I hope that we emerge as a type one
civilization now in outer space we look
for signs full of intelligent life in
outer space so far we find none
civilizations like type 1 should be
commonplace in the galaxy
some people assume therefore that type 0
civilizations are rather common but only
a few of them make it to type 1 because
that society for the first time in his
history has the ability to commit
planetary suicide so maybe that's the
reason why we don't see aliens in outer
space maybe they never made it maybe one
day when we have starships and visit
them we'll see atmospheres that are
irradiated because they had a nuclear
war atmosphere is too hot to sustain
life because they had a runaway
greenhouse effect maybe when we go in
out of space we'll see the corpses of
type 1 civilizations that never quite
made it who knows